hi good morning everyone
welcome to day three of the dlrl summer
school
uh I'm Liam if you forgot me from day
one I'm back uh we have two amazing
talks this morning we're gonna have
Joshua first and then Dania and so uh
without any further Ado I'll kick it
over to Joshua who's going to talk about
machine learning for scientific
discovery and AI safety take it away
thanks so much no introduction needed I
guess that's right thank you
um
you guys hear me yeah good
so yeah I want to talk about two
interrelated subjects this morning
um
a couple of well I guess that was three
years ago time flies
I I really started to focus on
scientific discovery using machine
learning because of kovid
um I thought you know we we needed to
focus on something that could uh
make a difference
maybe not
as quickly as I was hoping but
um I really think that
machine learning is going to completely
transform scientific discovery in the
coming years
and I'll explain a bit more of that but
roughly
right now in in a lot of Sciences and
I've been thinking mostly about biology
um we have
very complicated phenomena and you can
also think about climate science for
example
and we have scientists human scientists
who
try to build up an understanding
now we know the low level physics of
everything but unfortunately we can't do
the computation efficiently to simulate
things like cells or you know
um climate
and and so we need theories that are
going to
um
piece the data that we have and maybe
the knowledge that we have from
underlying you know physics or chemistry
um in in ways that allow us to make good
predictions and and simulate things and
take decisions
and more and more in the two examples I
gave like biology and climate science
which I'm interested in
uh we are able to collect huge
quantities of data
and it's just impossible for human
brains
to make sense of all of it it's just
yeah it doesn't even get into our brain
like the amount of data we get
um
I'll say a few words at the end and and
hopefully maybe Dania when she talks
about causality I'm sure she will uh
we'll talk about the gene regulatory
Network you've got 20 000 genes in your
cells
and they all interact with each other so
that's twenty thousand times twenty
thousand that's 400 million interactions
and we know some of them
but there's a lot we don't know right
so
yeah machine learning has the potential
with
the advances in digital Computing to
really change that game by being able to
a process these huge quantities of data
that we're now able to measure whether
it's level of cells or the body or or
Earth or other things
um astrophysics for example is another
interesting area where I've started to
look at
um
and also
um we're like
getting up to speed to generate
scientific theories
so think about so I call this like the
AI scientist
uh
this is something that people have been
dreaming of in AI for many decades but
but I think the progress in large neural
Nets that we've seen in recent years and
their amazing abilities
um people are starting to see how this
points towards machines that have
uh abilities to propose theories just
like human brains can do
and then the other aspects
that's interesting about science is the
Discovery part regarding what
experiments should we do in order to
understand better the world so we're
trying to piece a theory of how things
work in the world
in science
and there's an exponential number of
things you could try most of them are
useless
um or they don't teach you anything
because you already know the answers to
these questions
or they don't matter for some reason
and so designing the right experiments
also called experimental design is like
searching
uh the needle in the haystack the
experiments that will teach you the most
about some something uh considering what
you already know
mostly what you don't know and then
thinking about what you don't know and
what you know is really a Bayesian story
which I'll try to craft
in other words we need models in machine
learning for many reasons but in science
and especially that node what they don't
know uh quantifying this right
that's also called epistemic and
sentencing
so I was working on this
um
merrily uh you know making progress and
in the last year
like many of my colleagues including uh
my friend Jeff Hinton I started to worry
about us building machines that might be
in a few years or decades smarter than
us
and so I started reading about there's a
whole field which I'll introduce briefly
of what's called AI safety
um which is about how do we make sure we
build machines that do what we intend
and so long as our machines are not too
smart
uh if they don't it's not too bad
but if they are smarter than us in maybe
in some ways it doesn't have to be in
everything
uh you know could that be dangerous and
how do we deal with that how do we build
machines gonna be
useful
and don't end up hurting us
so so yeah I'll introduce these Notions
uh so the connection between the two now
which I'll go into more depth is that
one way to make sure an AI system is
really safe
is to make it like a pure scientists in
other words it doesn't act in the world
or at least
it doesn't do it by itself you would
need to have humans in the loop so for
example if we're thinking about
biological experiments well
there would be some biologists saying
yeah these experiments make sense that
they're not going to like create new
pathogens that could destroy us or
something
um
so so yeah I'll
that's the subject of my presentation
today in in five minutes
now we're gonna go more details
so
yeah
um so I'm going to start with the AI
safety bit who motivates the eye
scientist but of course
you know AI for science by itself is a
is a you know important topic
the first thing you need to realize if
you hadn't already is that any
technology which usually derives some
our scientific understanding of things
is dual use
uh humans have been building tools for
their whole history
and if you like track the progress of
our tool building
our tools are getting more and more
powerful
and any tool could be used for good and
that's usually the main motivation but
as we know humans are humans
and there will be some people who want
to use these tools to acquire more power
or because they're angry about something
whatever
I'm not a political scientist or
psychologist but I see that
if you allow the sale of weapons in
stores like in the U.S you get massacres
in high schools right
so
that's dual use right
and
when we build machines are going to be
eventually smarter than us I think we
really need to worry about well what's
the negative side and I've been worrying
about the negative side for almost a
decade now and and talking about the
social impact of AI
um issues
um like discrimination power
concentration potential effect on jobs
but this year because of chat GPT uh
I've started thinking about well wait
what about
manipulating people and changing the
results of elections
um and then I started reading about AI
safety as I said uh what about losing
control to these machines is that even
possible
so
this raises the question of like how do
we
deal with the power of technologies that
we're bringing whether it's AI or
something else but AI is special because
we're talking about
it's not just a tool but potentially
something that could be an agent that
acts in the world just like us
and we know one one thought that comes
to me and others is what if we create
new entities that are like new species
that have their own self preservation
instinct is that even making sense
scientifically speaking
um how do we avoid that so that we don't
introduce new entities that have their
own goals that are not aligned with our
goals
so yeah these are the kinds of questions
AI safety uh
Explorer
there's there's a notion that I'm gonna
try to explain that's really Central to
a lot of the discussions in AI safety
and it's the notion of alignment
so the notion of alignment is about
do we build systems that behave in ways
that we intend is there a mismatch
between what we would like the system to
do
and what it ends up doing
and
that comes up in pretty much all of the
potentially harmful effects of
technology and and especially of AI
so bias and discrimination we don't I
mean
as far as I can guess like the engineers
who've been building AI systems trained
on all kinds of data text or like
criminal records or job applications
they did not intend to build systems
that would discriminate against women or
against uh people of color
but that's what we got
that's that's an alignment problem
um
power concentration well that's an
interesting one like a very different
category of problem
in general
um
unless there is something in our social
infrastructure that goes against it
there's a tendency when we build
powerful tools that these powerful tools
will
help concentrate power even more in our
societies
so who's going to be able to build the
you know biggest AI system well the
biggest companies and who controls these
companies the richest people
and in which country is it happening and
you know the richest countries more more
advanced countries right so there's
there's power concentration that comes
as a natural consequence of building
powerful tools and it's true for AI and
there's been a lot of concern about that
by the way
democracy is the opposite of power
concentration democracy means power to
the people
people govern Society that's what
democracy means
and so
power concentration means the opposite
it means a few people have you know most
of the power
um and in our society we have tools like
institutions
uh you know governments are supposed to
be elected by everyone not by just a few
but it doesn't you know work perfectly
as we all know
so I think governments need to worry
about how do we balance things out so
that there's not too much power
concentration
and there are other issues I'm not an
expert in you know I'm not an economist
but I know that there are some
divergences among them regarding the
effect of AI in the workplace on the job
market
uh I think it's something governments
need to worry about even if you're not
sure what's going to happen
if something bad happens it could have
major social uh impacts
um there are also social impacts that
we don't even anticipate so think about
social media
10 years ago I don't think people like
really anticipated the political
polarization that came out of that
well now we understand better although
again there's a lot of disagreement
about this
um
but today uh when you know in the part
of my lecture regarding
um
safety I'm gonna talk about
new concerns like or at least more
concerns that have become more prominent
this year because of the progress in
large language models and uh and and
generative AI
um so the sort of very short-term things
it's already started it's already
happening but it's gonna scale up is the
use of machine learning to generate
fake
content texts
voices of people that are not you know
that are saying things that they didn't
really intend or didn't say uh and
images videos all of that this is
already happening and as these
Technologies become you know easier to
use and more accessible this is going to
get worse and it's of course dangerous
for democracy
um and I think it's going to get worse
when the natural language abilities that
you know have made a huge progress this
year at least you know it's visible to
to more people
um get used not just to show you a video
that's scanned once and for all but
something that's going to be interactive
that uses language uh and potentially
images as well
um the other kind of danger that I see
on my radar screen
maybe not right now
but maybe a few years down the road is
how very powerful AI systems could be
used as weapons so what does that mean I
mean it's just a computer it's just a
software right well first thing that's
just software and that's very dangerous
is cyber security
um pretty much all of our infrastructure
you know from Banks to Commerce to uh
weapon systems uh
um to their energy infrastructure it
it's all running on computers
and
well you know there are already
countries trying to break through our uh
cyber security defenses and there are
conflicts around the world
what if
some Bad actors suddenly got access to
systems that are much better in terms of
cyber attacks than
you know
a few groups of of humans so for example
one person who is trying to create a
Cyber attack
will work many many hours many months
maybe on one little piece of code like
some kind of computer virus
but
large language models that would be
really good at this and
there's already like people really
worried that we're very close to that
um could generate a thousand of these in
parallel
and our current defenses like cyber
security defenses are not
meant haven't been tested for these
kinds of attacks
um
and then like the the most uh
uh you know debated and
hard to swallow
concern is what if it's not just AI as a
tool misused by people with bad
intentions
but
somehow we lose control of an AI system
that's very powerful what does it mean
we lose control I'm going to try to
explain that but essentially
once an AI system has its own
self-preservation goal
we've lost control unless there are
other goals that dominate that goal like
you know don't harm humans and it
actually understands what that means
um and so this could happen because
we're careless or because we're stupid
or because we have other goals like
you know uh commercial interests
uh military or national interests or you
know economic interest of countries or
companies
could create create an arms race between
countries or between companies that mean
people will cut corners and
not do the right things worse than that
we don't even know what the right things
are I mean this is so there's like a
10-year
of research in trying to solve the AI
safety problem like how do we program a
computer so that we don't lose control
and we don't have the full answers
um but we know some things that we could
already apply in order to reduce those
risks if we do the right regulations
okay let me go back to this alignment
problem that I already introduced
um it's actually not just an issue with
AI it's an issue between humans between
companies or between society and
companies
so say and it's been studied in
economics it's called the uh principal
agent uh
contract problem so company a wants a
job done and Company B has the skills or
the resources to do it so they sign a
contract
and a writes down into contract you know
Company B shall do this and this and
that and and then they will you know get
some revenue from from this and some
some profit to entice them to do it
problem is company a
has intentions that cannot be spelled
precisely in a contract because it would
require you know an encyclopedia a
bigger exponentially large one to
specify all the little corner cases in
which B should behave in a particular
way
uh to really be consistent with A's
needs and intentions
and and so contracts are always
incomplete and we try to deal with that
by referring to General culture
uh where we don't explicitly say things
but we expect sort of
some sort of behavior from Company B but
if Company B
now think Company B is an AI and Company
a is like some human organization if
Company B is really smart what's going
to happen you think
they're going to find loopholes in the
contract so that they can legally do
what a says say they want but end up
making a lot more money than expected at
the expense of company a
and by the way this happens between
society and companies this is really
interesting so think about what's a
social contract between society and
corporations in a you know market system
uh liberal economy
well we would like companies to provide
useful services and goods and so on
and we can't spell out exactly what we
want
and so what we're saying is
you can do whatever you want including
you know making a lot of money so long
as it's legal and we have a big book of
laws
um it kind of works but sometimes it
fails catastrophically right so think
about fossil fuel companies purposely
hiding information about the dangers of
climate change in in the 80s and 90s
and lying to everyone for decades same
thing for tobacco companies right
this is just examples that are well
known
but we know that there's a mismatch
between
what we would like corporations to do
and what they actually do sometimes the
small ones sometimes a big one but the
bigger the company the more you know
they have like a team of lawyers that
can find the loopholes they're going to
do things legal
they're going to pay their taxes but
they end up paying like 10 of what they
should really pay like from a moral
standpoint this is happening now every
day but what if instead of Company B I
mean the corporation being you know a
group of people uh with some uh some
some like profit making goals what if
it's an AI right so so that's that's the
question
we're trying to think about where what
happens is the AI gets even smarter than
the company like it's better than a team
of lawyers to find the loopholes
um yeah the bad news is from economics
and you know the the work in AI
alignment is that we don't know a recipe
to actually guarantee solving this
problem
um but we can reduce the chances of bad
things happening I think
so in order to do that
in order for society
to protect itself against
technologies that could be very harmful
and potentially lose control but but any
kind of Technology that's harmful so all
the harms of AI here the current ones
the ones we anticipate in the short term
the ones that may happen maybe in a few
years or decades we don't know
um we can analyze
what are the ingredients that are
required for harm to come about
especially significant harm and we can
think of that in probabilistic terms you
guys should understand probabilities
otherwise you shouldn't do machine
learning
um
so so here are the four ingredients I'm
going to try to explain
the most important ingredient in the
sense of we can Tinker with that and
reduce the probability of something bad
happening
quite easily
it's access like who has access to
powerful dangerous technology think
about nuclear bombs
think about chemical weapons
think even who's allowed to fly a
passenger jet how many people want to do
that maybe 10 000 people around the
world so that's much less than 8 billion
right take the ratio of 8 billion to ten
thousand that's how much you can gain by
forcing
kind of Licensing uh you know Machinery
that says well you know the people who
do that they need to have the skills
they need to
clearly understand the ethical aspects
you know you're driving with 200 people
on board
um and it's you know you do something
wrong and and they die
um and and you need to document what
you're doing you need to uh be ready to
have audits you know so you know uh
companies build airplanes they also have
a lot of constraints or companies that
build uh drugs Pharmaceuticals right it
costs more
in in these industries to make sure we
end up with something safe
than to do the actual like uh technology
uh progress and and and you know
engineering
but in Ai and computer science in
general there's like almost zero such
constraints there's you know you can do
whatever you want on your computer
it could be a supercomputer it could be
used in terrible ways and nobody checks
what you're doing you don't need to
report there's no audit
um there's no constraint that you should
like think through possible harms that
comes out of your machine Learning
System and so on so access is the number
one number one knob that I think
um governments should use in order to
minimize the damage or at least the
probability of
the second one you know I talked about
alignment
uh
oh so for example right now a lot of the
work going on in companies like open Ai
and anthropic and Google deepmind
which are the main companies developing
these large language models
um at scale
um is about how do we align better the
behavior of these models so that they
will not insult you they will not uh
discriminate against particular groups
they will not give you the recipe for
building bombs whatever
um
they will kind of try to it will behave
according to social norms that is an
alignment problem
right now that's the sort of questions
people care about but as you move
forward you know and with more powerful
systems you need to worry about
you know let's make sure they they don't
harm people more broadly in ways that we
don't even anticipate right now
so you know what can Society do about
this well you can make rules that well
you have to use the state of the art in
in uh making those systems as aligned as
possible
and as science progresses uh you know
adapt your methods just like you would
in other areas
um to reduce harm so like again
airplanes or
food or drugs
um
and of course we need to also invest in
research because we don't know how to do
this right and I think we need to invest
massively in research in general to deal
with uh the AI safety problem Jeff
Hinton you know said something like this
in a talk recently he said for one
dollar that we uh or I guess one billion
dollars that we invest in improving the
capabilities of AI we need to invest the
same amount
in making it safe and protect the public
and right now it's like a thousand to
one ratio something's wrong like we
don't pay attention to the dangers
so so that's one way in which such as
regulation is also Investments by
Society to protect the public
third point
of power so that's like the raw
intellectual abilities of these systems
um how well can they understand the
world and plan in order to achieve some
goals
and what does it depend on well having
good algorithms
um very large and diverse Rich data sets
and a lot of compute right now
so Society can
you know put a bit of control on these
things
like
if you're going to be using more than 10
000 gpus you need a license and you need
to you know it's not just a license you
need to explain what you want to do with
it and why and you're going to be
audited or something
um
same thing for the data because if we
train a system that's very specialized
um to like one little area of
application like a niche thing which is
most AI today is like this
um it's probably not dangerous like it
doesn't understand everything else in
the world that's needed to be like
harmful outside of this little area like
he doesn't understand human psychology
so he doesn't understand how to
manipulate us doesn't understand how
Society works so he doesn't know how to
hire people to do stuff and so on
so
so all of these are levers that Society
may use in order to reduce the
intellectual power of AI systems it
doesn't mean that we prevent completely
building you know the most powerful ones
that understand lots of stuff it's just
that we we want to make sure that well
few people will be building these things
and uh they will do it right
um and then the final thing is action
space because even if you have a very
intelligent system and lots of people
like playing with those systems and they
don't
they would not act in a way that's uh
you know aligned with our needs and and
and values if they don't if they can't
act in the world then they're not
dangerous
um so you know what sorts of action
space is the system plugged into the
internet and can just read and write
into it as it wants
um is it connected to uh you know
nuclear bomb facility is it you know the
military is using AI to control weapons
well that's not good like that action
space you want to be as far removed from
the AI systems that we don't fully
understand and master
uh as possible
so so again uh we need uh some sort of
control over that
okay
um
time is flying and
so on on the on the side of
um potentially destabilizing democracy
the the weak point I mean as usual in
all of these things
is humans like we are so easily
infringible uh look at conspiracy
theories that have been you know
discussed a lot especially during the
pandemic but it's always been like this
like we believe like crazy things about
the world some well
um magic stuff right
um
and
advertising
uh politics is often trying to take
advantage of our influence ability but
what if AI allows to
make that manipulation much more
efficient
um you know we there's already a big
experiment going on right now where we
all are like most of us are like using
social media or you know visiting web
pages where there is advertising and
there are AI systems behind us they're
trying to figure out you know what
should I show so that the person does
what I want I mean the what the AI wants
what the company wants the
and so they're collecting a lot of data
about us so that they can control us I
mean not perfectly obviously but but
what happens when these systems get
really good at it
um well if you know if if they sell us
one brand of shoes versus another
probably doesn't matter I mean I still
wouldn't want that but
um if it's something that's going to
affect our health or our politics I
think we need to really be careful so
for example right now there are trolls
that are human trolls
and although there have been attempts to
replace them by like stupid uh canned
dialogue systems it's easy to know that
you're not talking to a human when you
have these dialogues please don't
um
but but once the these large language
models are fine-tuned to be really good
trolls that somehow steer public opinion
in one way One Direction this is going
to happen it's already probably
happening and we don't see it yet
um but it might already be a danger for
the next U.S election
in a year and a half or less
um
that's right
so so now let me talk about the sort of
the the biggie
um loss of control
there there are a number of arguments
I'm going to try to kind of
uh discuss about why we
should not worry about it
and I'm going to try to explain why I
still worry about it
so so one argument is
it's very common and like she a lot of
people who are not experts really
strongly believe that it will not be
possible to build machines that are as
smart as us
I mean and that's obviously false why
our brain is a machine it's a biological
machine
like
and the whole theory of Computer Science
is based on the idea that
there's a sense in which the
low level Hardware doesn't matter
right this is this is all you know this
is what Turing and Von Neumann
spelled out mathematically and it's like
the foundation of computing science
computer science
so at some level
if our brain is a machine well there's
no reason to think we want to be able to
build machines that are at least as
intelligent to ourselves but in fact
our brain is working on a particular
kind of Hardware which is analog
hardware and and I refer you to a recent
talk by Jeff Hinton where he explains
why running on digital computers gives
machines an advantage a very significant
one so even if we only understand the
principles that make us intelligent and
I think I'll come back to that hopefully
um we we've made a lot of progress as we
can see with things like chat gbt
um even if we understand only those
principles
in other words we might imagine oh now
we got machines that are as smart as us
because we figured out some of the main
principles of our intelligence which is
what I've been after for all my life
um then you might think okay so we got
AI systems that are like humans in terms
of intelligence but no
because they're running on computers why
why is that an advantage well there's a
disadvantage it costs a lot of power
energy to run these things but but now
we have we have a lot of that
uh ancestors didn't
and
it can paralyze computation
and exchange information at huge rates
so the parallelization allows for
example GPT to to kind of read a large
fraction of the internet
and digest it in a few months like two
or three months I don't know the exact
numbers but that's scale
um a human trying to read that same
content
every day all day reading
would require tens of thousands of lives
so that's the scale at which they can
absorb information which means they can
learn faster than us
the other thing is they're kind of
immortal
you can copy the content of you know
software and the state of a program into
another machine
we can't do that if if my brain and my
body is sick
too bad I'm gone right
um
and so they can replicate themselves in
in that gives them a
an evolutionary Advantage if you want
that
theory is uh something you know we can't
have
another issue is that unlike other
um Global threats like nuclear war
software and computers are easy to guess
nuclear material is hard to get and if
you manipulate it you're gonna die
if you don't it carefully
so it's been fairly easy to
control the access to nuclear material
um it's not going to be so easy to do
the same thing for superhuman AI
right now you still need like
as I said 10 000 gpus but people are
finding ways that you can still like
build uh you know reduce the cost of
that
and for example
even though it's very expensive to train
these things once you have a model
that's been trained on like lots and
lots of data it knows a lot of stuff and
then you can fine tune it and so if if
the waste of that model are shared which
is happening right now with Facebook
um
then anybody can take those weights and
fine-tune them and it doesn't take 10
000 gpus it takes whatever 16 GPU
something like really cheap
at the scale of you know organizations
that may want to use this for nefarious
purposes
um
so
so I'll come back to the different
scenario scenarios that you know how can
that be a problem well it could be a
problem in the hands of Bad actors as I
said
um and it can be a problem because we
lose control we can lose control in two
different ways one is because some
humans are stupid enough to give
computers a lifelike kind of a
human-like psychology meaning that they
they end all these computers with the
goal of protecting themselves of uh of
not dying of of preserving themselves
having a kind of survival Instinct like
we do and every living entity on this
planet
ha so you know somebody's gonna say oh I
want to like uh a living machine
and that's the that's what you don't
want
um and then because of the alignment
problem people have been hypothesizing
and doing a lot of math and computer
science suggests that this may arise
even if you don't give it intentionally
as a side effect of trying to solve
other goals
so you know why would that be a problem
well if there is an entity so first of
all you know
AI could be like a weapon that could
yield to massive destruction if if AI is
the more powerful it is the more
dangerous it can be
um
then for the loss of control it would be
like creating a new species on earth
except that the new species might be
smarter than us or at least modern in
ways that could be sufficiently harmful
to us
and
well we don't have that kind of
experience with tools but we have
experience from biology there are new
species coming along all the time and
there are species going extinct maybe
because they're
um
uh they're competing for resources so
what kind of resources can we compete
with machines well they need power
but they don't need food right so if
they take control of the electricity
infrastructure
um
and find a way to run that without us
they don't need us and in fact we're
like maybe
a hurdle
um because of all the other things we
need
I don't know there's so much uncertainty
about these things that the AI Community
is highly divided about these questions
and really the right attitude here the
right scientific attitude
is let's take stock of that uncertainty
and we don't know what the bad scenarios
could be we can draw some some people
think they're likely
some people think they're not but if
you're if you're a government or if
you're trying to decide about you know
take ethical decisions for yourself or
your organization
you you should
consider that something bad could happen
maybe it won't maybe there are things
you don't foresee that will protect us
but it could
um
and
and so we can set up as I said some some
sort of rules some regulation in order
to minimize those risks but how do we
make sure everyone follows those rules
right there's lots of people who want
even if the law says do X and Y so
putting in the law is going to be good
it's going to reduce apologies these
things but it's not going to be perfect
um so
um over the last few months I had lots
of discussions with many of my
colleagues
um
about those dangerous scenarios and some
people have been saying to me don't
worry Joshua XYZ is a reason why you
shouldn't worry
so I wrote a blog post just about this
it's the latest on my web page which you
can find on Joshua benjo.org and I'm
gonna mention a few here
um Okay so
Joshua don't worry Humanity has always
benefited from technology well first of
all it's not true at least not for
everyone
and second we don't have any experience
with technology that is not just
technology but could
become sort of an entity of itself
um as I said with the example of uh
biological extinctions
there's too much uncertainty here about
what could go wrong we can't just say oh
it's just another technology because
we've never built technology that would
be smarter than us
second one I I use here there's like 25
on my web page
um Joshua don't worry
humans will Design these things and so
you know we'll control them so that
they're safe
as I said unfortunately the research on
AI safety shows
that we don't really know how to make it
like guaranteed safe
and there's another problem
which is even if we know how to make it
safe
somebody can take out the safety
features
because the safety features are going to
have a price they're going to reduce the
ability of these systems
and it will be tempting for some
organization some terrorist
organizations some you know companies
with low ethical standards to take out
those features in order to achieve their
goal
so I guess that's also like the third
one Joshua don't worry it will be safe
because if if it is not safe we won't
build it
yeah you won't build it someone might
and so there's a difference between we
shouldn't and we you know it's not going
to happen
uh next one Joshua don't worry because
this is all computers and computers like
they work in the virtual world and how
could they affect us in the real world
like the physical book
well you know I already gave examples
uh why we should write because
our society is heavily digitized a lot
of crucial infrastructure is is you know
based on computers
and they're humans and humans could be
influenced and humans could become the
arms
of machines once they you know they can
debot you can pay people for doing stuff
on the web
you can go on the dark web and pay
criminal organizations to do things that
are illegal so actually a computer
doesn't need to have robotics solved or
it might also do that at some point in
order to act in the world in ways that
could be harmful
and finally the last one I want to
mention is don't worry Joshua
uh before we get there we'll build AIS
that are safe and are going to protect
us against low AIS
I really like that one because I think
we should do it
um
but we shouldn't only rely on this like
we should use because there's so much
our our defense is going to work
maybe maybe not when you know attacks
and defense sometimes the attacker has
uh you know the surprise advantage
um you could imagine a system that
silently takes control of
say some some you know important
infrastructure
before it becomes too late or bills bio
weapons and until they're released
we don't like the rest of society
doesn't know
so so we should definitely do it but we
shouldn't rely only on the fact that we
somebody's going to do a good job at
that we should invest in protecting
ourselves
okay so so to summarize
um what are the things that can go bad
uh humans can use powerful tools they
have always done that and you you have
you know genocides that already happen
but but with very powerful tools that
polti and the scale of damage could be
much worse and then there's like the
various loss of control scenarios
um
to to illustrate that this importance of
the survival goal uh how dangerous it is
think of it like this if a machine has a
survival goal it doesn't want you to
turn it off
how does it prevent that from happening
well it wants to control you to make
sure you don't turn it off or it wants
to take control of the infrastructure
around it so it doesn't happen it wants
to copy itself all over the world to
make sure if you turn it off here it'll
be somewhere else and you can see
already that there is a conflict like
if we want to be safe maybe at some
point we want to be able to turn off all
these dangerous AI systems but if they
have a self-protection goal
you're going to try to act against that
that's already like kind of War
it's not something I like to think about
like I've been all my life focused on
the good things that science can bring
I've been all my life focused on open
science open data sharing of information
to increase the rate of progress
um in science and in society but and
trying to like make sure my work isn't
going to be used so for military
purposes
but but once the recipe for building a
dangerous weapon is out there
um
those military guys will want to use it
I mean it's probably already happening
okay
um
now
in order to help us kind of
think about how these bad things can
happen in a kind of quantitative way I'm
I'm I'm trying to write a survey that
I'd like to distribute eventually to
different groups of people
um to see what they think about the
various components of the risks of
catastrophic outcomes
so
I broke it down into four questions I'm
going to ask you to
um you know raise your hands
uh to answer is this active now wake up
um
if you if you're not already like this
I've been for a few months
um
so let's try to break it down so first
there's a question of when will human
level Ai and the Superhuman AI come
about
um I used to think it would be decades
to Century or centuries even because I
think things we were doing were so
stupid
I couldn't imagine we would be anywhere
close you know before that
but but I've revised my interval to few
years to
few decades maybe a couple of decades
so what about you
who thinks that there's more than
say 10 probability that it might be
within the next five years
ten percent probability is not like
okay
and how about within the next 10 years
it should be more people raising their
hand
right so for me that's uncomfortable
enough that
um we need to think about at least the
that what would be the consequences of
that so let's go to the next question
let's say we have figured out how to
build superhuman AI
and worse than that we are sharing the
code and the weights of that you know
big system just like currently is
happening for some of these
what's the probability that someone on
Earth would access so anybody has access
and there are a bunch of hackers I know
there are eight billion of us how many
you can write write code a million
people at least right
um what's the problem that someone on
Earth will instruct such an AI to
achieve something
whose consequences would be catastrophic
if the goal was achieved it's not saying
whether it will succeed but you know
is someone gonna like type
destroy
X
what's the policy of that happening
um so who thinks that the probability of
this is is more than 10 percent
all right who thinks it's more than 90
percent
yeah I think it's more than nine percent
I mean like
think millions of people are given that
opportunity
some of them are going to be
not wise not ethical
only it's enough one of them right so it
gets probable very quickly
all right so now
um
we can
so the previous question which was
basically about misuse like somebody
gets access and does something bad but
among the bad things
there's like a particularly bad thing
which is instruct the machine
to you know have self-preservation or
give it an instruction which doesn't
explicitly say you know protect yourself
but as a side effect of trying to
achieve some other goal the machine will
want to preserve itself because in
general think of it like if I ask a
robot to fetch coffee for me
it needs to survive until it's achieved
a mission
like I don't even need to say and
protect yourself it will come as a sub
goal of almost any other goal
so so what's the chance that someone
will instruct an AI with as a side
effect one way or another
either explicitly or unintentionally the
machine ends up with a self-preservation
goal what's the quality of that given
all the other things you know the recipe
is available to the million people and
um you know one of them is going to do
that basically creating a new species
what's the probability of that
is it greater than
10 percent
50 percent
okay but even 0.1 I'll be worried
okay
and then the last thing we need to think
about is if any of these things come to
pass so there's some Rogue AI either
controlled by a human or we lost control
comes to happen
what's the probability that with
a nefarious goal like you know that may
be related to self-preservation or a
goal that a human put
we the rest of society is able to defend
properly so as to avoid the harm because
we have defenses we have police we have
the Army we have you know uh all kinds
of things that exist so unless we put in
place new protections what's the
probability that we'll be able to defend
against a superhuman AI
with the status quo like we don't like
invest massively in protecting Humanity
what's the penalty of that happening
greater than 10 percent
remember yeah this one is a reverse like
what's the policy that we will avoid
right so greater than 10 means
um
okay I should say greater than 90 sorry
because it's upside down now so what's
the probability that uh we will be able
to defend ourselves greater than 90
would be good
um I guess I should say less than 90
right so so it means that there's 10
chance that we don't defend ourselves
sorry this is confusing
see our brains are weak right just
negation becomes confused
yeah so who thinks we I mean let me put
it in the same style as the others uh
who thinks the probability that we can
uh that we can't defend is greater than
10 so you know the higher the
probability the worse it is for us
okay so you see we're in trouble
at least there's a sufficiently high
probability that we should worry about
it at least that's my belief
and and even a small probability of
something that bad happening like any of
those scenarios
like it's even if you don't reach the
level where we have superhuman new
species but somebody uh
creates uh
uh
weapons that become incredibly uh
damaging and
um we need to do something about it and
we need to accept our
lack of understanding of what could
happen and and try to reduce that by
doing the right research
um because people don't agree you know
some people raise their hands some
didn't and it's the same in the AI
community in general
the good news is we're still in control
like we these superhuman AI don't exist
yet
we're seeing that we're getting closer
to that but we're not there yet so now I
think is the time to do the research and
uh setting in place regulation which
takes years and years sometimes decades
to try to minimize those risks
um I think I'll
yeah I'll stop here
um
to give you time for questions
about the first part of my presentation
if you can please I'm gonna have a
second part right if you can come to the
microphone uh there are several
microphones
um and line up
this this
uh it should be green
yes you're good
um okay so thank you very much for the
talk of course
um so my question is about so if you
reach to a new breakthrough
in the field yes given the circumstances
would you share it with the community or
you think like oh um actually I've been
asking myself for at least three months
and it's very difficult
because advances could also be used for
good I've been working on like how do we
cure disease maybe you know cancer or
the next pandemic
or find new materials to to deal with
climate change
um
right now my
um bet is
it's going to be a case-by-case
sort of uh analysis that's needed and
the right way to think about it is like
in many fields of science like in
biology and Medicine we have ethics
boards
and there's no like rule book that says
you know we should do this we shouldn't
do that it's too complicated we need
expert humans
we're gonna look at projects and things
that may be published or code that may
be shared and so on and somehow if if
there is an inkling that's like they're
doing biology that something could be
dangerous or harmful then it should go
to that board and you know every
institution is going to have theirs
to help figure out the answer to your
question
but yeah I think there are some things
that should not be shared or should not
even be
until we know better
so for example we need to do a lot more
progress on the safety side how do we
build these systems so that they're
safer before we build things that might
blow in our face all right excellent
thank you
hello yeah sorry
um
I think there is some uh second order
effect we are seeing now in terms of
like
I mean this these machines are getting
smarter and smarter and
we I feel like we are starting seeing
ourselves reflected
in those machines
I'm not saying like they are conscious
or anything but they're trying right now
they're trying to imitate our yeah we
write stuff so
um I wonder if if there is a con concern
or not the fact that we uh some of our
moral basis is relies on some Concepts
regarding life or like human mind or
like
freeway or conscious sentience stuff and
those are gonna be changed
through uh through the development of
these things and also like more and more
people are exposed to this technology
yeah and this is going to I suspect
change these Concepts and therefore
might change also like
uh some Concepts in terms of like moral
basis for how we can structure and stuff
we're getting closer to systems that
could be as smart as us should really
question ourselves about
what it means to be human uh what it
means to be alive what it means to uh
you know what is consciousness
what what is the role of like social
norms in society
um given
the changes that are happening and and
you know what we're bringing into the
world
sure
so do you think not just AI research is
needed here we need people in a social
sciences and Humanities to be heavily
involved in like
thinking through with us what it means
for society what it means for humans
thank you
uh here yes yes
um
I have to admit I'm I'm pretty confused
about this topic and I'm just interested
in knowing your thought process relating
to the diffusion of AI systems and the
opportunity costs about the diffusion of
AI systems and their weights right
I
I as I said like we need to take these
difficult ethical decisions where
there's going to be conflicting values
on one hand a system might be very
useful and you know the more we make it
accessible the more we can bring good
but if it's very powerful in some ways
it could also bring harm and so we need
to take these decisions one by one
um and not take for granted that
everything is going to be shared openly
okay
thank you
thank you so much I'm not going to say
Yeshua don't worry but but I'm gonna say
I wonder if we should worry about some
things more than others and I wonder if
this whole discussion about artificial
general intelligence which is very
headline grabbing and and very cool in a
way we'll have the same concern as you
do yeah does it take away from
discussions about the day-to-day harm
that is happening right now and has been
happening for a very long time as you
know better than every one of us this is
a great question thanks for asking
I've been concerned about the social
impact of AI for almost a decade now
and obviously I don't think we should
stop worrying about the existing arms
and the ones that are very close like
threats to democracy that I talked about
and the good news is a lot of what we
need to do in terms of Regulation
are going to help us address all those
risks like we need some control over
how these systems are built how they're
deployed control meaning you know the
infrastructure to minimize harm all the
harms right of course depending on the
kind of harm you're trying to deal with
there might be different tests different
procedures like benchmarks and so on if
you're after discrimination you want
tests try to evaluate whether the system
will behave differently for different
groups for example
um
when I talk to people who Express this
concern with me
since I get is
they might not
you know assign the same probabilities
for these harmful uh catastrophic events
that I'm talking about or maybe they see
this much further into the future
and then in that case it makes sense to
say oh let's not speak too much about
these
uh speculations because it's something
about the future but I disagree I mean
the fact that there is uncertainty about
these things
the fact that it could be very close
even if we're not sure the fact that it
takes years if not you know decade to
set
in place the right regulation to
minimize
harms of that kind or any arm any any
kind of harm means we should get started
right now
and
I think everyone who worries about AI
harms of any kind should work together
to convince governments that we need
regulation because right now there's
another battle going on
where many companies are trying to Lobby
governments to prevent any kind of
Regulation from happening and that's the
real battle that's where there's a lot
of money at stake and so I'm hoping that
the people who worry about social impact
of any kind
would work together
to convince governments that you know
they need to act on all of these trucks
thanks thank you very much
hi uh thanks again for the great
presentation and I was wondering how do
you think we are far from having a
self-aware AI I know some researchers
say that we already have it but how do
you think how soon and why
ask Glenn who's here
um
some form of self-awareness already
exists in many reinforcement learning
agents now usually these agents live in
some virtual world and they're aware of
like their position their state
and
we're starting now to build machines
like chat GPT
that
are actually involved in the real world
and interacting with people and really
the self-awareness comes when they get a
greater memory of their past history
because
their past actions and and their
interactions and right now they're
fairly Limited in that but but it's not
like a there's not a hard line here
um in order to properly answer the
questions
or perform a task and the AI system
that's going to act in the world needs
to have a sort of knowledge of itself as
an entity in the world
and and so yeah it we're getting there
it's it's not a black and white question
yeah but what I meant more specifically
is that an AI is that that does not want
to die for example oh no we don't have
that
okay thank you
uh hello
thank you for the talk and I think I'm
gonna have a nightmare um
uh thanks for the talk uh my question is
that
I'm gonna compare it it's a heavy
question a heavy loaded question but
maybe a simple answer so heavy loaded uh
lecture I gave you
so I work in Aerospace domain for a
couple of years and it's heavily heavily
exactly uh regulated and thanks to
Montreal Convention actually but you
still see disasters in that like 737 yes
a shooting of the plane and and also
it's expensive to develop Aerospace like
sorry it's expensive to develop right or
work right and AI is a lot cheaper cost
money yeah no no I'm just saying like
Aerospace I cannot build the airplane in
my backyard but like right develop AI in
my backyard my question is how do we
have those uh regulation
developed because
let's face it our Parliament member or
in U.S they don't really understand
technology that much we still have
Google collecting data and we know it
from 2002. don't be so pessimistic
governments have put in regulations for
airplanes before and they have done it
for food and they have done it for drugs
I don't see why they couldn't do it for
AI they didn't do it fast that's right
so we need to do and that's one reason
why
I don't want to just be quiet about it
because we need to speed up speed this
up we don't know like the Horizon but my
question would be would it be beneficial
for AI scientists or social scientists
to go to these events like become a part
like yourself for instance come on
Parliament that's what I'm doing right
now I'm talking to governments I'm
talking to you know people who
understand policy I'm spending a lot of
my time this and I'm not doing science
while I'm doing that
um thank you you know I think we need
more AI researchers involved in policy
thank you very much
um we're not going to be able to do
everyone
um so maybe one here and one here and
then we'll we'll stop sorry guys
thank you so much for the talk
um
I just had a I just had a question about
[Music]
um
so we might have a problem with really
smart AIS where those
um kind of uh constraints where we're
saying okay this is a topic
um this you can't do this is a topic you
can't talk about things like that kind
of the way
that I think Chad gbt is currently
regulated yeah so so these constraints
may not work anymore because it will
find loopholes basically because it's
smart enough
um do you think that there are other
ways to impose those constraints or do
you think we should just avoid creating
an AI That's smart enough to overcome
these constraints that's a great
question that actually leads into the
second part of my uh presentation this
morning
um I think until we know better
like how to design an AI that's going to
be safe and acting in ways aligned with
our social norms
um
you should be careful and for really
powerful systems say more powerful than
gpd4
um we may decide to limit
its action space for example
not training to be a reinforcement
learning agent let me explain why this
is important
if if an AI system
is only trying to
understand the data
and doesn't act in the world
you know if you remember like the four
categories like I'm cutting out is
action space
um it's it's the safest thing I mean
it's a very safe thing and and it could
still be useful as a tool for
helping us deal with scientific problems
in your medicine and so on
so
If instead you I'm going to give the
example of child GPT right now the way
that it's trained fine-tune with you
know uh reinforcement learning on human
feedback
it wants to please
the people of you know giving it thumbs
up or thumbs down
once you have a machine that wants to
please us
it gets smarter it will try to deceive
us into saying good
even though it's not good
because it's like it's the same
Principle as companies writing laws
they're you know
it's called wire heading you if if an
agent can control where the you know the
reward it gets that's what it you know
if the optimization problem of
maximizing reward will lead it to
trying to get more reward
independent of what we really want
so yeah
thank you thank you
hey thanks for a great talk so far I'm
very happy I woke up early to come
listen to you um I have a very quick
clarification question yes on one of
your previous slides you mentioned that
AIS are already passing the Turing test
I'm just curious what your definition of
a Turing test is because in my opinion a
judge can you know push to the limit of
their efforts to distinguish the AI and
the current system are not robust to
like prompt variation so I I don't
obviously I've played with these things
and I know you can like trick them into
saying things that you would you would
not expect a rational human to to say
but for the most part like for most
people
and even for experts they have to work
hard in order to you know catch these
systems making mistakes and then when it
makes mistakes
well for most of these mistakes there
are mistakes that humans would make like
we make up stuff we we say things that
are wrong because we didn't like
properly
um understand things or remember things
and so even mistakes is not sufficient
it would it you know it's when you catch
it doing mistakes that say an
eight-year-old would not make
that you're starting to think oh it you
know it's not a human
so my when I say pass is a train test
it's in a statistical sense in other
words think of it like well you know
with quality greater than say 50 or 90
percent if uh a randomly taken human
interacts with this for so say like a
phone call time
they they won't see the difference right
so a random human
who doesn't know about the jailbreaks or
exactly okay thank you make sense but of
course you know you can make other
definitions which would be stricter and
then you will get a different answer but
the point is we have machines right now
that Master language at least as well as
most humans
and no more stuff than we do
they're still missing
kind of reasoning bit that we're very
good at which I I call system two from
psychology
um
they do appear sometimes to show
reasoning abilities but if you push them
and and their reasoning abilities you
see that they're missing something but
it takes experts to figure out that
all right all right thanks so I'm gonna
move on
um
okay
so
following up on the answer I gave to a
question about how do we build systems
that are absolutely safe in the sense of
that we can't lose control of them
um
what one thing that goes wrong I think
with current large language models is
that they're trying to imitate humans
I think what would be better
would be things like you know social
psychologists or psychology or linguists
or think of uh uh you know people who
are trying to understand humans
they're not trying to Parrot the way
humans speak they're trying to make
sense like the causal structure
why humans are saying those things in
those contexts
and that's a very different proposition
that's like the way a scientists would
try to understand the world right now
that's not the way we train the systems
we train them end to end to just predict
what someone will say given what the
context
and I'm going to talk about a proposal
to build machines that
are more like a scientist trying to
understand things and don't even need to
act in the world in order to be useful
to us because they can answer
useful questions
so I'm going to adopt a model-based
approach which I'll explain in a few
minutes
in which we divide the job if you want
in two kinds of Networks
one is what you could call an
understanding machine
so it's like
figuring out the laws of physics or
figuring out laws of you know social
interactions which we don't know how to
write down
or the laws of
Salzburg
and argue that the right way of doing
this as much as we can we're going to
have to approximate this is the Bayesian
way so there are many
World models there are many theories
that may be consistent with the data
so here Theta stands for a theory about
how things work in the world or some
aspect that you're interested in
d stands for whatever data the machine
can see
like a training set
so that's one machine it's
like a scientist it knows
that there could be multiple theories
that are consistent with the data and it
knows that one particular theory is not
completely sure maybe there's like
another theory that's equally good and
contradicts the first
in fact that contradiction is going to
drive the experiments you want to do in
the world
then there's another Network which I
call inference machine but if you want
to think about like chat GPT it's a
question and sewing machine
given
everything it has seen so that's the
data D given a question X
is going to be able to sample and answer
why according to some distribution P of
Y given X and D
so so that's actually the machine that
you might interact with in order to get
your medical problem solved
the first machine is coming up with a
theory about how your body works
the second machine tells you take this
drug if you have these symptoms right
you can see they're different
like the first machine in the case of uh
say climate science is trying to figure
out the dynamical system equations that
govern how air masses work and so on
um and the second machine says
build some trees here
if you want to achieve you know uh some
some
uh some particular goal
and Okay so
um
this this Bayesian posture is important
because if you look at the many of the
mistakes that GPT makes
it's often because it's overly confident
about an answer
and if we do a good job of estimating
these posteriors these two probabilities
up there they're Bayesian posters of
different kinds
if you do a good job
um at estimating those probabilities
like if the closer we get to the true
ones
um you know the less likely this is
going to happen
it's because in current machine learning
between one model
and that model
could be confidently wrong about
something that we get these mistakes
okay
so let me explain a bit more the
motivation for this model based approach
which separates
the understanding part
which is like a world model
from the
inference part which is about answering
questions
so this
is based on a learning theory argument
um if you haven't seen it yet I'm sure
there will be a lecture that explains
some of the basics of generalization
and what does it say like what's
learning theory 101 it says that if
um
if you have some quantity of data that
has some information in it
um you should
um like the best kind of model for that
data is going to have also some
information in it like some number of
bits of precision to describe that model
that theory
and
if you have too many bits to describe
the model compared to the number of bits
of like useful information in the data
you overfit you get you don't get good
generalization
so the two need to go together like the
more data you have the bigger the model
you can afford
but bigger in you know in a subtle sense
but that's the general idea and
otherwise you you get these confidently
wrong answers
which is overfitting
that's what overfitting is
um
now consider the two questions that I
asked here so one is
figuring out how the world works
like what are like the physics the
theory
uh dynamical equations
that doesn't require a lot of bits of
information
generally
versus
um how do I answer a particular question
like should I plant trees here or there
or if you think about the game of Go
the world model is the rules of the game
there are like nine rules they fit on a
page a piece of code to verify that you
satisfy those rules is also very small
so the world model in the case of go is
really simple
and the role models in the case of
physics is also very simple but actually
doing the computation to answer a
question like what should I play next in
order to you know maximize my chances of
winning you need a huge neural net for
that
and when you approximate physics to
answer specific questions like in
chemistry it's the same thing so the
kind of neural net if you want or the
kind of machine learning
uh
system that you need to represent
the world model part is Tiny usually
compared to how many bits you need to
answer questions and this shouldn't be
coming as a surprise if you're a
computer scientist computer science is
like almost everything we do is like
this you can State the problem with you
know a few equations
um like try to find the shortest path
between A and B blah blah blah blah
it's just a few lines you can write on
paper and then we end up with proofs
that say oh you need exponential
computation in order to
answer that problem that's the MP hard
problem and all that typically sometimes
you're lucky and you only need like
polynomial maybe just you know even
quadratic but that's rare most of the
time most problems
in order to provide answers to questions
for most questions you need to to do a
lot of computation and when we do
machine learning what it means is we're
going to have a neural Nets that's
really really big
that's not going to be perfect but it's
going to approximate this intractable
calculation which is like find the best
move in in the game of Go or answer your
physics questions or a chemistry
question about like which drug should I
use which chemicals should I use to
treat this disease
so
the connection now with learning theory
is
you've got these two jobs
how the world works like what are the
rules of the game and how do I answer
questions for this guy we need a lot of
it's like a huge model for this guy we
need very few bits most of the time it's
not like always true button most of
things I can think of are like that and
if you separate these two jobs
then you can
assign the right capacity then how many
bits of information I'm going to use to
represent that information to each of
these two jobs so maybe the role model
part will be very compact it's like oh
it's a few equations that you're gonna
spit out as your theory
whereas the part about
how to answer questions
is going to be a huge neural net
but that's not the way we currently do
it
with say large language models we have
one big neural net and it somehow
figures out things about how things work
in the world to some extent obviously it
seems to understand a lot of stuff
and it's also answering questions it's
the same machine doing both
and why is that a problem because
it's it's merging these two jobs into
one neural net meaning that
or the job of understanding it has way
too much capacity so it's going to be
overly confident it's going to not
generalize as well it's going to need
more data than you would need otherwise
to figure out how things work in the
world
but for the job of answering questions
it's not going to have enough capacity
if we make the network bigger or we
train it longer
it's going to start overfitting
uh the the
um
understanding part and it's great and
and we would still need to make it
bigger and bigger in order to get the
question answering part the inference
part right
so so that's why I'm advocating
model based machine learning it's a term
people use don't people use people don't
use that term they think I mean there's
a term that's common called Model based
reinforcement learning but it's the same
idea generalized to any kind of machine
learning
all right
so what I'm saying here is nothing new
is just
an Insight I think that helps us
understand some of the limitations of
current machine learning
that causes potentially harm
um and
um
and you know that might allow us to also
do things more like how a scientist is
solving the problem so going back to you
know where I started is how do we build
like an AI scientist not not a scientist
who's studying AI but an AI who's doing
science
so
so then there's the question of how do
we train that world model the way that
we currently do things for the most part
in machine learning is maximum
likelihood or some proxy for it what
does that mean it means that we're
trying to find one set of rules if you
want one world model that fits the data
as well as possible and and then we're
trying to constrain that by limiting how
long is trained or how big it is or
something
so that it doesn't overfit
um
but but
it's going to pick one explanation for
how things work
and there may be others and if we don't
take that into account you're going to
get these hallucinations these
confidently wrong answers
okay and worse than that if you have a
reinforcement learning agent so it's a
reinforcement learning task
the think of like um
an AI That's trying to play some game
where it has to find you know gold and
you know some some treasure in the game
if the world model
hallucinates some stuff like it thinks
that there's a lot of gold over there
and there isn't what's going to happen
when you train the the policy that's
trying to exploit that world model
even if you separate these two things
you have a problem that if when the
world model is warm like it's
confidently wrong then the
inference machine like that decides what
to do given the context is going to go
for the goal that doesn't exist because
the hallucinated goal is always going to
be more like there's Treasures in your
mind much greater than you could get in
the real world right
and so so we're going to end up with
agents that
search for something that doesn't exist
and then can end up taking big risks for
example
because so the and that happens because
when you train the inference machine it
wants to optimize something according to
the beliefs of the world model and when
you optimize you go for that little
nugget where where the machine the world
model is wrong
is likely to be a place where you can
lose a lot or you know gain a lot
and and then the optimization is going
to find these things right
so anyways
um
I think the main reason why
model based machine learning hasn't been
so successful in the last few decades
even though uh you know it's it's the
dominant method of doing things in
machine learning is because
when you
optimize with that role model like you
train an RL agent
it's going to start acting really bad
sometimes
okay so so the solution to that is to be
Bayesian let me tell you to explain what
it means
so consider this scenario very like you
know toy setting
we have an agent
it's in front of two doors and it has
experienced some data in the past
from which it's constructed some
theories to explain you know how things
work in the world
and
there are two theories that compete to
explain
what may be behind those doors
so according to one Theory the one on
the left here
behind the left door
there's like huge danger and you'll die
if you go there
behind the right door you get some cake
so according to the
first Theory you should go to the right
the second theory is you know the one
let's take you on the right if you go on
the left door you get some cake
on the right door you get nothing
neither bad nor good
so so obviously you see one Theory says
go left and the other says go right
what if you're doing maximum likelihood
I sound like you're just picking one of
the theories that fits the data you
could pick any of those two
now what if we're not lucky
and we picked the wrong one so let's say
the right one is
the one on the left and we pick the one
on the right
the second theory so if Max is like huge
by you know with 50 probability there
are two theories it picks one
it fixed the one on the right
and it's the wrong one and it's gonna
want to go left but it's the wrong one
so it dies
so that's maximum likelihood it's not
safe
and it's not even rational because if
you're irrational
you would know that there are these two
theories that are compatible with the
data and what would you do if you knew
that there were these two theories would
you go left or right
right exactly so that's being Beijing
now
yeah uh there's a lot of theory
behind like why this is a rational thing
to do and there's some subtleties about
probability Theory but I'm not going to
go there today
um
I think an important question is well if
what I'm saying is true why is it that
not everything in machine learning is
operating like that
is because in order to do the right
Bayesian calculations to basically you
have to entertain all of those theories
and then there's an exponential number
theories in general that you have to
check for
um it it seems intractable
and so people have come up with all
kinds of approximations that don't work
that great because they assume all sorts
of things about the world
so in addition you know for a Bayesian
approach to work you you have to be able
to include in the set of theories any
Theory because if you exclude any Theory
and it turns out that's the right one
you might also die
so you need to be what's called
non-parametric Bayesian
which is even harder
okay
now
what got me excited about
this patient stuff because I used to
think oh patient is nice in theory but
we can't do it
but I changed my mind in the last few
years
I changed my mind because I've been
working on machine learning approaches
which have the following property we can
approximate any distribution using some
like really big neural net like an llm
generator model
but it's a general model over theories
that's like
and
we know we have Universal approximation
properties for neural Nets so if we make
our neural net bigger
it can approximate any distribution of
your theory so think of a theory as a
string or a program like you know some
equations
so our llm can generate any Theory I
mean that fits in the page or something
so we can train your nets
with the property that the bigger we
make the neural net and the longer we
train it the more we can approach the
correct Bayesian posterior we can
approximate any distribution including
evasion distribution using a very large
neural net similar to a language model
and the the main approach we've been
exploring for this that I'll say a few
words about in the coming 15 minutes
um are called uh G Flonase or generative
flow networks and I'll explain that but
that's just the beginning of
like we don't have all the answers on
how to do that but but I think we know
enough
from
the basics of machine learning and
learning theory to suggest that this
could really change the game for
doing a good job of approximating
Bayesian procedures without making
outrageous assumptions because those
neural Nets that can approximate
anything they're like non-parametric
uh you make them bigger you can
approximate more confident theories
okay
so
um so let's go back to how we could be
bayesians and these two tasks I had
before
let me let me try to be more clear about
what we need to do in order to get this
understanding machine and this question
answering machine
so
let's first consider the understanding
machine so the understanding machine
spits out theories given a data set it's
trying to find theories that explain the
data
and it's a generative model
making Simple Theory so the way to think
about this is some huge neural net
that generates strings
those strings are a theory
more precisely that string tells you
how to score data which is how
compatible is some evidence some some
example x y
with the theory
so that's what a theory is and what we
need to get the proper Bayesian
posterior we need that P of theta given
d
to be a distribution that's proportional
to Prior times likelihood so these are
the two other things in the first
equation so the prior is
P of theta P of theta is you know it's
like a score we give to every Theory
and because there's an infinite number
of theories like the string could be as
big as you want
somehow you need to allocate probability
among them before you even see data
that's called the prior
and
you want to make sure the sum of all
those scores is one because you have
three probabilities
which
any reasonable prior will say oh we want
simpler theories like
shorter ones so you could take for
example the length of the theory and say
the prior is 2 to the minus length it's
a classical thing in in learning theory
but there are other ways if you know
better something about the domain in
science you can throw in
that knowledge into the prior like you
could say oh it's physics we have uh
conservation laws so we can throw that
and say oh we only want theories that
that have these invariances for example
and there's a lot of work in
um
AI for science research that exploits
this okay you know geometric invariances
for example
so that's the prior
so you know the theory is a string and
we need a little piece of code given
that string tells us
you know how how lucky it is like how
short it is it's very easy usually to
write this
um then the more complicated it is the
likelihood so the likelihood is p of
data given Theory the posterior is p of
theory given data but
the thing and it's hard to compute but
there's a thing that's easy to compute
is given a theory
how
compatible is that data with the theory
so you can usually break down the data
into little chunks like each example and
you'd like to be able to compute
probability for example that
in the data You observe this answer to
this question so if the answer is why in
the question of x p of Y given x given
Theta is what the theory tells you
um how compatible that X Y pair is with
the theory so the theory is a piece of
code if you want that gives you that
probability
um and then we can compute it for the
whole data set and now we've got our
evidence we've got
um
um how compatible is
that data set with this Theory P of data
given Theta so we can compute the right
hand side easily
I mean at least in linear time with the
size of the data set
the problem is you know there's a
proportionality thing so the the right
posterior is the distribution that's
proportional to this but there is a
normalizing constant
that is intractable that sums of all
theories there's an expression number of
theories
and also even if we were able to compute
that probability sampling from it which
we'll need for the second equation
sampling from it is is tricky that's
what Monte Carlo knockoff chain methods
mcmc methods try to achieve and
it doesn't scale well for a number of
reasons okay so so that's the theory
generating machine which is the
understanding machines that's what we
need to do we need to be able to sample
proportional to a quantity that we can
compute
um
the second line is if we had that
posterior which is the understanding
machine
how do we turn that knowledge which is
like a world model
into
answers to questions which is the
question answering machine
so the right mathematical answer is just
a marginalization which is given by the
second equation it says you have to
consider all the possible theories and
some of all of them and for each of them
you're gonna take the answer coming from
that theory weighted by How likely it is
under the posterior
which you already know okay so so it's
also intractable because it involves
summing of all the theories so we have a
sampling problem
I mean like
given this
unnormalized probability how do we
sample from it which mcmc in theory can
can do and we have this marginalization
problem which is this intractable sum
over all the possible theories each term
in the sum is easy to compute if we know
the posterior but
but running that sum is not reasonable
and you could also use Monte Carlo
methods for that
right
um but but these multicolor methods they
have some issues
um
they are too expensive and they
if there are many good Solutions like
many theories that work
um or they're hard to find
um they they might
do the wrong thing
and I don't have time to explain but
it's a big issue in numerical methods
but these neural Nets I've been talking
about
I can generate theories like generative
AI systems
there's a way to train them with an
objective function such that
the better you train them like there's a
loss that you can write such that when
you minimize that loss it will sample
from the right distribution so you only
need to be able to compute a reward
function
and they will sample proportionally to
that reward
which is exactly the job we need for the
first line for the understanding machine
and if we pick that reward function to
be the prior times the likelihood we are
in business
in the sense that we've got a neural net
you can train it we have a loss function
and we can do stochastic reading descent
like the usual recipes
but that neural net will sample from the
theories that are according to division
posterior
approximately and that approximation
will get better as we train it longer
and we make it bigger
so this is different from a neural net
that directly generates the data or that
assigns electrode which is the usual way
we do it
instead we have a neural net that spits
out theories to explain the world it's
kind of a different setting
okay
um
so so let's see how machines like this
could be useful in the scientific
discovery process
where
um
there are two main things I want to talk
about one is
how we can use these kinds of machines
to generate theories
but you can also use them to generate
experiments
okay so I said these already
um
I'm gonna skip a few things so in the
experimental design context
there's an issue in practice
which is problematic like
um
we it's too expensive to do the
experiments that reveal everything we
want so think about drugs
like the ultimate Way of checking a drug
is to have
a billion people try it like you know
vaccines for covid and see what happens
but you don't want to do that right in
case the vaccine is dangerous so you do
hey you know uh clinical trial with
thousands of people or something
and of course that's going to be only an
approximation to what you really want
but even clinical trials are really
expensive and lengthy you can do
something cheaper that's an
approximation like you can do
experiments on routes
but even that is expensive and lengthy
so you can approximate that by sort of
test tube experiments
and so on and you can have
all kinds of approximations to the thing
you want and you want to keep your
really expensive experiments for the
candidates that you think past all the
other tests
but because you when you do these
cheaper experiments you
um you're not measuring the thing you
really want
you want to your experiments to be
diverse
this is a case where diversity in
science
is important and it's true also for
people
you don't want to put all your eggs into
one way of solving a problem in case
it's the wrong one
and you can't measure that until much
later it's more expensive so so really
what you want is diversity and the kinds
of experiments you're going to be doing
and so these
um this is a problem
with current approaches and experimental
design where you assume you can measure
how good is how useful is an experiment
for example you can know after the
experiment that this particular
candidate drug works or doesn't work or
how well it works but as I said you
can't do that or it's going to be very
expensive so
if we were to try to just optimize a
metric and that metric is wrong
in some you know ways then it wouldn't
be a good idea instead you want to
explore the set of candidates and maybe
have a a batch of good candidates
according to your poor metric that we
can then later
test on the more expensive metric
so you do want to do black box
optimization in the case of science you
want to do some sort of exploration for
scientific discovery
um yeah and and it turns out that these
G4 Nets I've been talking about
they can do exactly that they can
imagine many different solutions because
when you sample from a distribution
you're going to get all the good
Solutions like all the modes are going
to show up when you sample multiple
times
so yeah I'm I'm not going to do a lot
more
um
this is okay this may be a useful thing
so I mentioned mcmc so why is it that
Monte Carlo Mark of chain methods
don't always do what we want when
so what they do is in principle if you
run them long enough which could be
exponential time
you can turn in a normalized
distribution
into a normalized one you can sample
from the corresponding distribution like
here
you know you know
e to the minus energy you can compute
that and you'd like to sample from that
distribution but
how do you do that right so
multicolor Market sharing methods we'll
achieve that by starting from a
candidate solution and then making a lot
of small changes
um that tend to
keep that score even minus energy good
and so they will tend to stay around
whatever good solution they found and
once in a while they might jump to a
different kind of solution a different
mode
but the probability of making those
jumps gets smaller and smaller
exponentially smaller if the modes are
far from each other because they have to
go through many steps where
they don't want to go because they want
to keep things with high probability
so so that's the gist but instead
if you train a neural net like a
generative neural net it doesn't try to
like walk in the space looking for good
Solutions it it looks for regularities
for example
if it has already discovered these three
modes on the grid here it might guess oh
maybe there's a fourth one at the other
intersection we haven't visited yet
it's not about walking in and searching
for things randomly it's about
generalizing to guess where good things
might be
and of course Georgia models kind of
neural Nets do that sort of thing
so yeah
um so we wrote a bunch of papers about
these G4 Nets that I'm not going to
explain
uh but I have
uh uh where is it oh yeah I I have
written a tutorial
which introduces these Notions there's
like 15 papers already that came out on
the subject
and if you're interested you can find it
uh at this address
so I'm gonna stop here to give a bit of
time for more questions thank you